as president biden stumbles and
democrats look for an alternative the
liberal media is hard at work trying to
rehab the image of kamala harris the new
york times essay blaming joe biden for
the troubles of his vice president with
the headline kamala harris is stuck in
adding quote she is hampered by mr
biden's unpopularity to be sure but she
has also not become the successful
public face on any major issue that mrs
harris has been stuck in a political
role is troubling for anyone concerned
about the stability and continuity of
the executive branch but reality check
kamala harris has only herself to blame
for how the public perceives her check
out this awkward moment
so when i think about what we need to do
to address mayor
and what ultimately does
so often fall on the shoulders of our
mayors to address
on a community level
jessie i can't imagine why she would be
unpopular or hasn't had an achievement
that's been handed to her by the vice
president i'm going to take an
artificial stance
because i want to blame joe a little bit
okay joe should be grooming kamala
not in the perverted way i see your face
gut fell i'm talking about the way uh
maybe eisenhower groom nixon you know
delegated a lot of major stuff a mentor
right so
eisenhower had a heart attack during his
presidency
joe biden's 80.
kamala needs to be able to step in and
make major decisions when uh
was a truman came into office i think
his first month he had to decide whether
to drop the a-bomb on japan whether to
do the berlin airlift um you know he had
major decisions and i don't think kamala
could come in and do anything so
she's supposed to have lunch with the
with joe biden they don't even have
lunch anymore she's supposed to be
having lunch with the secretary of state
that's been a standing thing for many
many presidencies and and what's his
face over its states iced her out so joe
has only given her things that he didn't
want to deal with or they weren't going
anywhere like voting rights on the board
he hasn't given her any position where
she can shape policy he only picked her
because she was a female of color and
then once he got elected he just kicked
her to the curb so he should be grooming
her to be the heir apparent and he's
failed to do so how was that as an
artificial stuff that was pretty good is
that good that was pretty good that was
pretty cool
so jessica i mean it is true that vice
presidents typically get portfolios that
are harder politically so the president
can be more popular but that's not
working for joe biden so is it unfair or
has she just not risen to the occasion
i think it's a combination of all of it
and joe biden also has personal
experience with getting a crappy
portfolio because it's a thankless job
being vp right you're there for whatever
you can bring to the ticket that was the
same thing barack obama famously didn't
want joe biden to be his vp and david
plouffe and axelrod said
this is the right person if you want to
win and they ended up bffs by the end of
it and they have the bracelets are they
still bffs i don't know i think
it's a separate conversation i i still
think that they love each other but you
know he did happen to pick someone who
dropped out before iowa yeah right this
wasn't someone who you know made it to
the end or had a distinct cohort of
support um that was very widespread it
was very targeted and specific and i
don't think that there's any fault or
shame in making sure that you have a
certain kind of voter i mean donald
trump picked mike pence for a specific
reason what do i have a problem with
white evangelicals what does mike pence
solve for me white evangelicals um but
she needs to get on board with this is a
thankless job i need to make it my own
and add you know some flair and pizzazz
to it and have a better reputation and
he needs to make sure that he's
supporting her as much as possible but i
actually think that he does a good job
of doing that so judge we're a year and
a half in when do you think she's going
to start as long as she still has a
staff because everyone keeps leaving
it's one after another after another
after another after another how many
have left 13
something crazy number look americans
are forgiving and americans are very
understanding
it's almost as though we could look back
on the last year and a half and say okay
maybe it's joe's fault i don't think
it's joe's fault folks not joe's fault
she is who she is but
i don't blame joe i don't blame the fact
that she's in a position of vice
president and therefore gets the tough
jobs that's nonsense
you are a vibrant woman at the prime of
your life you are vice president of the
united states you've got the energy
you've got the stamina you're quick
you're sharp you've run for office
before you should be out there every day
doing something i don't care if he gave
you the
uh the border to deal with you should be
out there getting women together getting
business people together baby formula
whatever it is you get out there and you
be heard you're not controlled by joe
biden he doesn't tell you what to do you
can do what you want to do so don't give
me this garbage that oh joe biden is
giving her a chance she's lazy and she's
not interested that's why she's a
failure so greg she has been successful
at one thing
getting on your show
that's right she's uh we have we you
know we find out that she's quite
irresistible if you supply bongos when
she talks because she's like a beat poet
i think joe knows that kamala is the
best decision he ever made because no
one wants him to go anywhere i pray for
his health every single day because then
it's her
the golden rule of being president the
vp should be half as competent of you as
you and joe's already incompetent so
that makes her zero confidence this is
why harris will never be president
because she won't be able to find
anybody worse than her to be vp
every candidate is going to outshine her
so unless they like not if she picks a
box of wet wipes you know if we decide
that we can have an inanimate object as
a vp then she could run but this is it
goes back to the original point there
isn't a single problem that she's been
able to solve whether it's crime
inflation fentanyl which we're
discussing in the next block or the
block after that instead they put all
their eggs in that january 6 political
basket but that that that theater did
not put food on the tables it didn't
catch any criminals it didn't have any
effect on inflation and uh uh people saw
through that so they're kind of in a
bind so to speak jessica and i would
argue that wet wipes are pretty useful
greg they are they are but don't flush
them on the toilet that we will yes it's
really annoying that you can't
yeah i know it drives me crazy i did it
for years before realizing it's bad for
the environment
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else